it's a really sad news especially
when children are here to study to make
their future better a devastating crash
that's causing grief to those in two
different continents the collision
killing five men in their 20's all
indian nationals it's really painful for
the family the crumpled metal all that's
left of one of the vehicles involved
it was just before 4 am saturday
officers with opp were called to the
westbound 401 between aikens and saint
hilaire road there was a two vehicle
motor vehicle collision at that area the
collision occurred between a tractor
trailer and a passenger van opp say
there were originally eight people in
the vehicle but then the van came to a
stop on the highway and one person
exited the vehicle the collision
happened while seven occupants were in
the van five were killed two others
taken to hospital with serious injuries
the driver of the tractor trailer was
unharmed it's the first time i've seen a
collision to that magnitude it's just a
horrible tragedy harpreet singh
jaspender singh karan paul singh mohit
chauhan and pawan kumar were all killed
in the crash it leaves an impact and it
leaves you kind of shocked the men were
studying in montreal and the gta there
is an inherent appeal for a better life
to canada to moving into you know canada
you have better education in some cases
obviously the appeal of being able to
build a life in canada community members
are now stepping up to support friends
and family of the men who died to their
friends
who are who are going to a grave
grieving process we are there to try and
help provide counseling services
officers with opp are continuing to
investigate the crash at this point no
charges have been laid
we spoke with a man in india who
identified himself as a relative of
powan kumar he says kumar came to canada
18 months ago and he described him as a
hard-working man who came here to study
and make a better life for himself he
says he and his family are devastated by
the loss erica bella global news